hello I'm usually andrew heaton and this
is mostly weekly strength it's like a
Craigslist version of John Oliver this
week journalists Hollywood starlets and
Trump administration officials will all
congregate in Washington DC there to
pretend that our nation's capital is hip
and glamorous instead of a
self-important nerd bog I speak of
course of the White House Correspondents
Dinner a boozy soiree that I refused to
attend look the White House
Correspondents Dinner isn't a good thing
you don't want politicians and
journalists getting chummy there's a
reason that we keep animals separated in
zoos and that's not to keep them from
fighting it's to keep them from forming
alliances so I refused to attend hello
hello yes it's me I can make it I
haven't asked out of my trunk Uncle Bill
just yeah just excuse the safari no I'm
all in favor of journalists binge
drinking and chain-smoking or even mood
lining as superheroes but an important
part of being a journalist is throwing
rocks at whoever's in power left or
right print or TV journalists need to
come together to make the president's
life hell democracy works best when
media and power have an antagonistic
relationship it's like if your parents
have a divorce and they're competing for
your love through expensive gifts if you
want that nerf gun for Christmas you
better tell Dad that mom is getting
plowed by the tennis instructor shindigs
like the White House Correspondents
Center throw the whole Washington
ecosystem out of whack and when that I
can go I have a cummerbund hello
genny's I can't talk about Star Trek
right now I'm doing a thing yeah kelsey
Grammer's and start rings in the next
generation he plays Captain Morgan Jason
he cries every movie they made Spock and
emo Vulcan hey Jennings I got to go I'm
still doing that thing
where was I now you might be thinking
hey the White House Correspondents
Dinner is kind of like a roast
sometimes the speaker is antagonistic
like when George W Bush got destroyed by
Steve Colbert or that time Jimmy Carter
got ripped apart by a tiger but most of
the time the people they are getting
along inflating each other's egos
following each other on Instagram and
entirely forgetting me I believe
journalists should keep a respectable
emotional distance from politicians
because I'm a wasp and I believe
everyone should be emotionally
unavailable yes yes
emotions are hard here's the suggestion
have you tried making a graph also the
Fourth Estate speaking truth to power
Free Press and so on and so forth you
read it so instead of a White House
Correspondents Dinner I've compiled a
list of approved events politicians and
journalists can participate in you can
read that while I drink scotch
because here's the crux of it right now
the media loves pelting President Trump
and that's great
they should absolutely be doing that but
four years from now they're going to
give a free pass to President Oprah last
year under the Obama administration we
bombed seven countries the journalists
wanted to talk about North Carolina
stupid bathroom law because of the drug
war we have the largest prison
population on the planet but we heard
more stories about Pokemon go and the
truly important thing hello yes I can go
okay sure yeah I'll sit and Tucker
Carlson slap that's fine okay I'll be
there in a minute thank you I have to go
to a business convention at the work
place
good chat good
[Music]
you
[Music]